la petite reine à ces petits princes 26
enfants de 8 à 11 ans qui en six jours
vont avaler en vtt 120 km deux mille
mètres de dénivelé de bibracte à alésia
entre coups de pédales coup de pompe et
coup de main voici leur histoire
[Musique]
en ce deuxième jour d' aventure c'est à
pied que ses élèves affronte l'oppidum
de bibracte regard du fait de vélo mais
la visite de ce site archéologique
majeure la capitale des et du 1-1 des 40
peuple gaulois
alors la marmite ça va servir à faire
mijoter pendant qu'on a une viande qui
va être très dur à mâcher et ben en fait
on va la faire cuire plusieurs heures là
dedans jusqu'à se soient bien tendres
donc les gaulois pour ça qu'ils vont
manger beaucoup de ragoût les muscles
sont laissés au repos après l'étape
difficile de la veille pas les neurones
par petits groupes les enfants partent à
la découverte de la cuisine est celle où
s'immerge dans l'intérieur d'un gaulois
en flux en paix imaginez le risque aux
lois qui marche et là-dessus pieds nus
pour rentrer dans une pièce chauffée par
en dessous où il transpirait et après et
revenir et c'est pour se laver
une maison très confortable pour se
mettre dans la peau d'un riche gaulois
en train de bâtir la villa de ses rêves
ou déguster un gâteau inspiré de
l'époque et en deviner les ingrédients
ces visites guidées ludiques ont
rassasié l'appétit de connaissance de
ses élèves mais il n'avait pas les
prouvèrent la can à suez prenait tout ça
donc ils étaient obligés de prendre du
miel pour le sucre et des abricots il y
en avait pas d fricou moi je répond
vraiment à vivre au temps des gaulois si
elle va beaucoup de cheveux vraiment
cette visite au musée elle est géniale
parce qu'on apprend plein de choses
qu'on savait pas avant
et c'est nos ancêtres dont les connaître
un peu quoi ils sont à fond ils vont
vouloir tout cet archéologue je pense
alors toi qui est ce qu'ils pensent
qu'une femme pouvait être le chef d'un
village gaulois le bibracte alésia ce
n'est pas que les jambes c'est aussi la
tête
retour quelques semaines plus tôt dans
la classe d'anne lise ses élèves
travaillent sur la société gauloise
comme pour le vélo il commence à en
connaître un rayon cela irrite de
nombreuses matières la lecture les arts
la géographie et bien sûr l'histoire
alors est-ce qu'on peut répondre à la
question alors eh ben oui la faje l'égal
de l'homme pour être druide c'est vrai
que les gaulois les romains fascine
beaucoup j'ai de la chance mes élèves
sont sont très investis ils ont soif
d'apprendre enthousiasme en cours
enthousiasme à l'entraînement aussi pour
préparer leur aventure ses élèves ont
bénéficié en amont de nombreux cours de
vtt dans les vignes tout autour de leur
village
[Musique]
comme toujours l'un des organisateurs de
la classe vélo les encadrent les
conseils ce jour de mai c'est christian
qui est à la manoeuvre
c'est une petite descente qu'a toute
simple on va adopter et rechercher la
bonne attitude de bourges les deux pieds
la même hauteur allez hop
certaines jambes voilà pasta select et
je l'assumé
lors de cette séance le ciel est
capricieux le terrain plus difficile de
nouvelles sensations pour le groupe
devient on se promène comme ça on
s'entraîne sur les achement avec la boue
ils ont énormément progressé au niveau
des plateaux de changement de vitesse
les descentes
voilà moi c'est pareil j'apprends parce
que je ne savais pas faire de vtt contre
la boue les flaques d'eau voilà où quand
on aura pris encore des choses cet après
midi
quelle que soit la météo les élèves
restent motivés un état d'esprit digne
d'un guerrier gaulois mais sans la
crainte que le ciel leur tombe sur la
tête